[Music]
on this Saturday night's earthquake
devastation
[Music]
horror on the streets of Morocco it's
going backwards and forwards and
everything started moving
the rescue mission the casualties and
one Canadian's tense Story of Survival
from the disaster Zone it was really
really scary
startling consensus the softening stance
against Russia's Invasion on day one of
the G20
shooting for a culture change as Hockey
Canada aims to carve out toxic
masculinity I just look at history and
it continues to repeat itself why one
xnheller isn't buying it
global national with paranasser
panic and disbelief on the streets of
central Morocco in the immediate
aftermath of a powerful earthquake the
strongest to hit the country in 120
years more than 2 000 people have been
killed in more than two thousand others
have been injured most of them are in
critical condition there are fears the
number of dead will grow the 6.8
magnitude Quake struck Morocco's High
Atlas Mountains and flattened historic
buildings in Marrakesh the city closest
to the earthquake's epicenter
roads are impassable meaning it could
take days to reach some of the hardest
hit villages in Morocco's remote
mountainous region tonight Karen
Lieberman on the death and the
devastation
rescue workers comb through the rubble
in a race against the clock as they
struggle to reach the hardest hit most
remote areas of Morocco a powerful
earthquake destroyed buildings and
crumpled homes across much of the
country
we were harmed in The Old City we were
harmed by the earthquake said this local
resident everything is God's will but we
sustain great harm with widespread
destruction in ancient cities and
Mountain Villages the military and
emergency services are scrambling to
find survivors who could be trapped
under piles of debris it was going
backwards and forwards and everything
started moving and pictures started
moving and so we've every we just
grabbed grabbed some clothes and our
bags and we raised at Canadians in
Morocco are urged to register with
global Affairs Canada and in Toronto
disaster relief charity Global medic is
already sending urgently needed Aid
we've offered to deploy a drone team
that would be civilian operator is
Pilots small drones support search and
rescue activities second we've offered
family emergency kits which you can see
the volunteers behind me are packing and
making right now
saving lives is the priority with many
still feared to be trapped under the
rubble but preserving Marrakesh is also
meaningful for teams on the ground it's
home to a number of UNESCO world
heritage sites including the famous red
walls partially damaged
parts of town which are
which our car is completely destroyed
and the buildings are falling down
Bonavista Newfoundland Mayor John Norman
was attending a UNESCO conference and
had just arrived back from the city's
historic Medina when the shaking began
the hotel ceiling is cracking the light
fixtures were falling from the ceiling
Sirens ambulances
bodies being removed it's it's quite
something fearing aftershocks people
will spend another night in the streets
as the North African nation begins one
of the biggest recovery efforts in its
history Karen Lieberman Global News
as you just heard the Tremor is the
strongest to hit the country in more
than a century and there was a huge push
to get Aid flowing into Morocco and
mobilize what will need to be a massive
humanitarian response Canada's largest
Moroccan population lives in the city of
Montreal and today relatives of those
caught up in the chaos spoke about their
fears and their hopes for their loved
ones Gloria henriquez reports
at this Moroccan Cafe in Montreal
Saturday mornings are for soccer but
news of the tragic earthquake back home
is all these montrealers can think about
it's a black Saturday says Mosley has
seen the first thing he did when he
heard about the earthquake was call his
family in Casablanca
they were shocked and surprised he said
they slept on the streets fearing an
afterquake Adil bumais originally from
Rabat says he stayed up all night
watching the news
there's a feeling of helplessness being
so far he says the earthquake
shookumaraakesh Where Montreal City
councilor sir sashville was vacationing
and I thought that someone was taking a
carpet under my feet because
it was like there was no ground under my
feet it was really really scary with
such a large Moroccan population local
politicians took to social media to
react to the news Montreal mayor Valerie
plant saying in part the images from
Morocco break our hearts my thoughts are
with the Montreal community of Moroccan
origin Quebec Premier francology echoing
her thoughts adding that he's visited
several magnificent cities in the
country at this Moroccan butcher shop
located in an area of Montreal called
little maghreb kantari Youssef says the
local Arabic community at large is
banding together to get through the
tragedy
we will soon start collecting donations
he said
Cafe as yasim sees the death toll Mount
by the hour
he says he's hoping the nightmare ends
soon Gloria Enriquez Global News
Montreal
during the opening session of the G20
meeting in India the host country's
prime minister Narendra Modi offered his
condolences to those affected by the
deadly earthquake saying the global
Community is with them and ready to help
on day one at the summit the leaders
including prime minister Justin Trudeau
reached a consensus on the war in
Ukraine calling for peace but as Sharia
Israel reports Ukraine's foreign
Ministry is criticizing the Declaration
because it does not directly mention
Russia
Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi is
determined to put his country's best
face forward
and that includes a plan to keep some
things out of sight the authorities
asked us to leave she says because of
the G20
bulldozing slums and bolstering security
Modi has staked his reputation on the
summit going off smoothly even if some
of his measures are controversial this
really is India's moment in many
respects not just the G20 but the lead
up to the G20 over the past year with
several ministerial engagements the b-20
meetings the lunar Landing the Indian
prime minister is trying to propel his
country as a rising superpower and a
counterweight to China whose leader Xi
Jinping skipped the meeting Mr Modi will
come out of the summit as the leader of
the global South tool do a lot
for the developing countries for
development and it'll all be done
without Mr XI here so he can't claim any
credit for it at all there were doubts
the G20 countries with differing views
could come to a consensus on the war in
Ukraine India has taken a neutral stance
in the conflict
G20 leaders Summit declaration power
samati bani a compromise was reached
earlier than expected but the joint
statement appeared to have a softer tone
with no explicit mention of moscow's
aggression or a Russian withdrawal from
Ukraine outlined in the communique from
the last G20 Summit in Bali Bali was
Bali and New Delhi is New Delhi I mean
Bali was a year ago to contact you know
the situation was different senior
government sources with knowledge of the
negotiations say Canada wanted to see
stronger language in the Delhi
declaration but they insist that at the
G20 it's always a give and take prime
minister Justin Trudeau will meet with
Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi on
Sunday the last day of the summit
Ukraine which was not invited to the G20
has slammed the Declaration saying it's
nothing to be proud of pharah
isri in Delhi thank you
the war in Ukraine has triggered a sharp
rise in the number of people killed or
injured by cluster Munitions an annual
report funded in part by the Canadian
government found there was almost an
eight-fold increase in cluster bomb
casualties last year and this Redmond
Shannon reports those figures don't even
include this year's controversial
shipment of weapons to Ukraine from the
United States
when the United States said in July it
was sending cluster Munitions to help
Ukraine even kiev's closest allies
including Canada and Germany were
critical of the move human rights groups
outraged we were appalled by that
decision we fought it behind the scenes
for the year leading up Canada is among
the 112 countries that prohibit the use
production and export of cluster
Munitions but the U.S Russia and Ukraine
have not adopted the 2008 convention
non-cluster munitions
it means the use of the devastating
weapon is widespread in Russia's
Invasion the cluster munition
coalition's annual report says the
number of known casualties in cluster
attacks went from zero win 2021 before
the war to almost a thousand last year
the vast majority civilians most in
Ukraine the Coalition also recorded
cluster casualties blamed on government
forces in Syria and Myanmar the vast
majority of the cluster munition attacks
in Ukraine during 2022 and into 2023
have been conducted by Russian forces
however it's clear that Ukrainian forces
have also used glass diminutions
causing civilian harm Ukraine and Russia
deny using cluster bombs near civilians
the weapons are also lethal because of
the unexploded mini bombs Left Behind
casualties from those events Rose by a
quarter last year most were in Yemen and
Iraq 71 of them children these remnants
are particularly devastating to children
they're interesting they are often in
areas where children play the total
casualty figure is the highest since the
first report in 2010 the data was
compiled before Washington's delivery to
Kiev the greatest obstacle to countries
working to eradicate class diminutions
are the governments that are unwilling
to join this convention the report also
calls for quicker clearance programs for
cluster remnants alongside clearing
landmines that will be a huge task in
Ukraine one that is growing by the day
Redmond Shannon Global News London
conservative convention coming up the
Federal opposition takes its policy
priorities ahead of the next election
foreign
as the conservatives ride a wave of
support from opinion polls the party
wrapped up what's likely its only policy
convention before the next federal
election the Gathering in Quebec City
attracted a record number of more than
2500 delegates and they now have
recommended a diverse set of policy
proposals they want their party to
campaign on our David Aiken looks at
what's being proposed
let's bring it home
conservative leader Pierre pauliev fired
up delegates Friday night with an
hour-long campaign-style speech and on
Saturday the delegates got down to the
hard work of picking the policy
priorities they want pauliev to campaign
on this convention started with 60
policy proposals but half of those
failed to make the final cut among those
that passed conservatives want a foreign
policy that is tougher on China an
expansion of rail infrastructure
including high-speed passenger rail ramp
up investments in clean technology while
supporting oil and gas production we
value environment economy and our health
it's about jobs and balance that's what
Canadians want and need thank you our
energy transition policy highlights how
the federal government can work with
local communities to meet the future
energy needs of Canadians prohibit
discrimination based on vaccine status
ban minors and those with mental illness
from medical assistance in dying and ban
gender affirming medical treatment for
minors this is not just a federal or
provincial or Municipal issue it's
around the world we need to stand up for
kids among those policies that failed
conservatives rejected a call to defund
the CBC and its French language service
Radio Canada that's because such a
policy could have hurt the conservatives
here in Quebec where radcan is seen as
an important cultural voice
but under the party's rules it is the
leader Pierre poliev who has the final
say on what policies will be in his
platform he can reject some that were
approved this weekend or bring back some
that failed and there were some
Grassroots conservatives here that
thought that gives the leader too much
power and they had put forward a
proposal to change that but that
proposal failed
so what will be in the next conservative
election platform well we're likely have
to wait a couple of years to find out
until the next election and it's an
election not likely to take place until
the fall of 2025 Farah David Aiken in
Quebec City thank you David
[Music]
Executives at Hockey Canada have spent
the past two days in meetings in Calgary
tried to make the sport more safe and
more inclusive but just last week a
former NHL coach who was fired for
making racist comments was rehired Bill
Peters was named head coach of the
elethbridge Hurricanes junior hockey
team that apologized to the victim he
used racial slurs against former nhler
Akeem Alou
two King
I apologize
I now recognize the impact of my words
I was uneducated in my use of
inappropriate language
I failed to create a safe place for
Akeem and I'm deeply sorry
it's been more than a decade since the
comments were made and more than four
years since Akeem Alou came forward with
these allegations ALU is no longer
playing professional hockey but he is
involved in trying to bring diversity to
the game I had a chance to sit down with
him earlier this week
I came thanks so much for joining us
first let's start with that apology
what's your reaction to it
you know someday was very difficult to
see obviously the the emotion that was
displayed doesn't really correlate with
um the way the Outreach towards the
victims which is myself and obviously
the stories with Michael Jordan as well
I think when you're that sorry about
something that happened so long ago I
think the first thing that you got to do
is is just get in contact with the
victim and to understand where they're
at and how they feel about it I hope he
was sincere in his words and his emotion
but I always look at the action behind
it I haven't heard anything from him in
13 years and four years since it's
become public at the end of the day I
hope that this is a teaching moment for
a lot of people and we move on in a
positive light from here do you think
speaking out hurt your hockey career 100
I didn't say anything for close to nine
years because I was scared of what was
that gonna what that was going to do my
to my career and it's actually proven to
be right and I was in the middle of
still playing when I went public in 2019
and ever since then it's been really
difficult to get opportunities to get on
the ice and get a fair shot to have one
person be able to take that away from
you and I use it as a tool to support my
family in so many ways just because of
our financial shortcomings and for
somebody to come and take it away and is
really difficult and it's something that
I'll battle with the rest of my life
that's for sure Hockey Canada is holding
a summit this weekend and they're
looking at the issue of toxic
masculinity but also the issues of
racism I think trying to kind of clean
up the image that hockey cannabis had
for for several years now do you think
that's going to make a difference or a
dent I I just look at history and it
continues to repeat itself in the game
of hockey obviously the way they handled
the 2018
sexual allegations was very difficult to
see and just how far they dug their
heels in and it took public outcry to be
able to see change within the board and
and at the CEO level you look at all the
steps taken backwards by the NHL with
inclusion nights and and stripping
people of that 15 minutes of being able
to show that it's a welcoming and
inclusive space I think getting the
right people in the room is more
important than anything at the end of
the day we still have mostly white folks
running these establishments and I think
to talk about toxic masculinity and
their issues of racism and misogyny in
the game you need to have people around
that have actually dealt with those
issues you're doing some incredible work
on the ground with the hockey diversity
Alliance that you're working with kids
just starting your hockey journey into
minors we know that race-based incidents
still exists there's data to back that
up but what kind of incidents are we
still see today it's so sad if you only
saw the kind of the inboxes the reach
out to our inboxes we get of racial
issues and I mean it's it's two three
four times a week all over Canada all
over North America kids saying they've
been called the n-word indigenous kids
not being welcome Asian kids being made
fun of when you reach out to these
organizations and we talk about having a
very strict policy it takes a long time
to get anything done if the kid doesn't
feel included in the game there's it
doesn't matter the talent level or the
passion they have towards the game it's
something that they don't want to
continue doing it's very difficult to
explain that to a ten-year-old that you
know things will get better and you do
have support it's things that I've dealt
with things other guys in the HD have
been going through for their whole lives
hockey has become a very elite and very
white Sport and it's only getting worse
and money is kind of the ruler of hockey
we're trying to show kids that the game
can be inclusive and that's what we're
doing with the HDA Grassroots program
and we're having a lot of success you
just said it's getting worse why is it
getting worse I would think it would be
getting better with all that we know now
it's getting worse because hockey's
getting more and more expensive when I
played AAA hockey of course it was 15
years ago but we were paying three
thousand dollars as a family to play AAA
hockey now we're getting upwards to ten
thousand dollars to play the game of
hockey so it excludes a large
demographic from the game right away so
the work that we're trying to do is
trying to close that Gap and open it up
to more people and I don't understand
why the establishment continues to push
back on it because it'll make the sport
better if you had a kid knowing what you
know now about hockey college I just had
a kid two months ago you just had a kid
two months ago yes wow congratulations
thank you know what you know now would
you encourage him to get into hockey
it's a it's such a hard question part of
me says yes but I do want him to reap
the benefits of playing in a more
inclusive space and I hope it gets
better and in other ways and this makes
me extremely sad as well I don't want
them to deal with what I went through
his mom doesn't want him to deal with
what I went through but at the end of
the day I love hockey with a passion it
was my first love it's always going to
be my true love and I hope we can get
the came to a space where all kids
including my son can feel loved in the
game and pursue it and and make it the
greatest game in the world because I do
think it has that potential okay thanks
so much for your time and your passion
thank you so much appreciate you having
me
[Music]
dealing with
heartbreaking scenes from
[Music]
Morocco has a long road to recovery
after last night's devastating
earthquake so many are in mourning we'll
leave you tonight with heartbreaking
scenes and harrowing stories of what
unfolded there this is global national
for Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser take
care of yourselves and have a good night
she's in a certain amount of panic
people really don't know what to do a
couple of walls inside my house
collapsed while I was sleeping which was
pretty terrifying I can tell you to wake
up to that there's a certain surreal
experience waking up to an earthquake
but um you know I think my my worries
and my heart goes out to people living
in traditional homes or even houses that
were poorly built we're getting mixed
pictures there's no official guidance
coming from anywhere that we've received
we don't know what to do next
slept on the street last night so there
is a lot of garbage around from people
sleeping outside not necessarily damaged
for outside than inside their homes Lark
and I are very resilient people so
people are working they are going back
to their lives but nobody has never
lived an earthquake of such a magnitude
you're not in control of anything you
know you're waiting for the words to
happen
[Music]